bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce premier set 8 week-end de la
saison nouveau format désormais nous
allons revenir pendant 26 minutes sur
les moments forts de l'actualité loisirs
culture et sport de la semaine au cours
de cette émission n'est vous nous
évoquerons avec sylvie là où la
directrice divine tourisme la deuxième
édition de paroles de jardiniers qui
prendra ses quartiers cette année dans
le domaine national de versailles
mais place tout d'abord à l'événement
culturel du week end je veux bien sûr
parler du festival coup d'état pour sa
deuxième édition les artistes féminines
sont à l'honneur axelle red jennyfer ou
encore la louise dans l'émission
culturelle kiosques ce mercredi aurélia
de bissy a reçu les organisateurs
accompagné d'un membre du groupe
barioz libre et c'est un concours de
circonstances ces clés dernière on avait
une programmation avec des hommes et on
se dise les n'y a pas que les hommes qui
représentent leur rock en france là où
la musique est donc dès le départ de la
formation on a réfléchi à votre
formation avec des femmes et puis
finalement on fait en mesure qu'on monte
la programmation s'est aperçu qu'on
pouvait complètement monter une soirée
100% féminine où les femmes prenaient
doit recevoir de laroche est justement
ces artistes et bien on avait travaillé
avec un détourneur déjà avec le goût de
kiev n
et puis l'année dernière et puis sur un
coup de fil voilà j'ai demandé quels
artistes étaient disponibles c'est là
qu'il m'a parlé de rose et et d'axelle
red
et puis on voit là un guide et vient
finalement d'un petit collectif comme
tout aux formes tout à fait et puis ça
c'est monte au fur et à mesure et puis
après thomas qui est l'autre amateurs
avec moi
j'y tiens j'ai du grand hamster triste
qui vient de cergy voilà s'appelle rémy
là ça peut être intéressant
et puis au fur et à mesure pourquoi on
sait pas une soirée 100% féminine et
voilà c'est parti
et puis après le petit en plus féminine
ça veut dire que les femmes vont prendre
le pouvoir sur nous de tout faire
voilà toute une soirée où les femmes
sont au pouvoir voilà et puis pour finir
là sur jenifer voilà c'est à noter que
jenifer c'est important parce que c'est
sa dernière date tout à fait fondé de
france voilà après ne jouera plus à la
rentrée va repartir sur the voice et
puis peut-être un prochain album et puis
mais c'est sa dernière date en tout cas
en ile-de-france alors moi je vous
propose qu'on regarde un teaser qui nous
donnera l'étendue justement des groupes
présents
comment
sa trace
comme à ça
ça
hier javier blanco vous vous représentez
barioz livre est donc c'est un groupe
vous êtes yves in war 3 dites-nous déjà
juste comme ça vous trop dans quelle est
la signification de baby horrible alors
barillot libre est en fait si on traduit
littéralement ça veut dire quartier
libre donc d'une part c'est le quartier
libre donc le temps dont on dispose pour
faire des choses sympas en l'occurrence
répéter faire des concerts etc des rats
mais ça veut aussi un symbole est aussi
un quartier qui seraient libres donc un
quartier on a tendance à stigmatiser les
quartiers la légende d'un quartier main
peut faire exactement la même chose que
ceux des villes importantes que ceux qui
habitent à la campagne on est libre
voilà donc ça donnait une sorte de saint
souffler une sorte de vent de liberté
dans qu'on trouve peut-être dans une
musique aussi
ils ont trouvé que ça avait de l'impact
on aimait bien ces deux mots barillot
libre et alors c'est un espagnol
la plupart de vos chansons sont écrites
en espagnol doctement est espagnol ben
oui je suis espagnol l'espagne c'est
vrai que je baigne dedans depuis je suis
tout petit puisque jeu espagnol et
parents sont espagnols mon frère
d'espagnols qui fait partie du groupe et
on aime bien cette façon de j'ai pas mal
de facilité à écrire les textes en
espagnol ça me parle beaucoup mais plus
ça va plus on avance plus on écrit en
français également plus on adapte c'est
autre chose mais ça commence à nous
plaire vraiment bon comme on peut
définir justement votre style musical
le style musical bien c'est très rare
qu'on a on a une tendance de plus en
plus rock avec un côté un peu plat non
et très mélodieux c'est ce qu'on essaie
de faire des choses qu'ils soient
dynamiques qu'ils soient énergique mais
qui sont en même temps planante et qui
qu'ils aillent qu'ils aillent à
l'intérieur des gens nés c'est de
toucher la sensibilité des gens
et si vous voulez voir tous ces artistes
sur scène rendez vous au stade du bois
mort pas ce vendredi 6 septembre dès
19h30 et samedi 7 à partir de 15 heures
dans le cadre de l'opération partageons
nos cultures la maison de la poésie
propose jusqu'au 18 octobre
irene a une exposition sous forme sonore
de sylvie gastaud autour du discours
historique de martin luther king
le 28 août 1963 résonnaient à washington
le célèbre à have a dream
cinquante ans plus tard à guyancourt la
maison de la poésie rend hommage au
discours de martin luther king à son
rêve éveillé d'un monde meilleur
elle accueille jusqu'au 18 octobre une
exposition sous forme d'installations
sonores originales et participative on a
demandé à sylvie gastaud une dentellière
du son de collecter des sens un petit
peu partout ce qu'elle a fait
merveilleusement puisqu'elle a demandé à
des poètes et à des gens de lire le
texte de martin luther king dans une
vingtaine de langues différentes dont du
gaulois par exemple du grec l'espagnol
de l'arabe et caetera et on va retrouver
tout ça plus ou travail d'enregistrement
qu'elle a pu faire dans les collèges et
les lycées les écoles tout au long de
l'année sur la thématique du rêve et
surtout du rêve qui correspond à nos nos
missions c'est à dire montrer que la
poésie est un une parole d'unité une
parole de de paix une parole de
réconciliation c'est un vrai pouvoir
civique que possède la poésie et donc
elle le met en avant objets d'époque
band archives poèmes traduction
documentaire autant d'éléments qui
ponctuent la découverte du visiteur ce
qui m'intéressait par dessus tout dans
ce discours c'était les langues
c'était de faire converser les peuples
de travailler sur les coûte entre les
langues entre les peuples ou 9,1 même
des langues avec les accents je suis
parti avec l'idée d'enregistrer le
discours dans l'indre l'indifférente en
écho à l'exposition sylvie gazeau
présentera le 13 septembre au cours
d'une performance sonore et musicale le
dream de babel une proposition du
discours de martin luther king
traduite en différentes langues et
accompagné au saxophone
j'en parlais au début d'émission s'ouvre
demain ce samedi 7 septembre la deuxième
édition de paroles de jardinier pour en
parler sur ce plateau elle vient de me
rejoindre sylvie là où la directrice des
mines tourisme bonjour à vous bonjour
alors cette deuxième édition de paroles
de jardiner sur presque un mois jusqu'au
29 septembre il va y avoir sûrement des
moments forts j'imagine oui alors il ya
quatre temps forts un qui commence
dimanche puisque c'est la visite des
jardins du des trianon avec alain
baraton qui est notre parrain et qui est
le jardinier en chef du domaine de
versailles
donc il fera visiter à plus de 100
visiteurs qui répondront présents à
l'appel
les jardins des trianon et il fera
découvrir les trucs des jardiniers de
lenôtre et de tous ceux qui ont conçu
ses jardins alors ça c'est le sait le
premier temps fort le 8
ensuite nous avons le 15 l'arboretum de
chèvreloup qu'il a à titre exceptionnel
va faire ouvrir ses serres tropicales
donc c'est la première fois qu'on l'ait
qu'on les verra enfin une des premières
fois qu'on les verra
et donc c'est cet arboretum c'est
vraiment un espace végétal où il ya 2500
arbres de tous horizons qui viennent de
tous les pays du monde
et puis troisième temps fort port royal
des champs qui n'est pas très loin d'ici
et à port royal et bien là on découvrira
les plantes médicinales avec des
démonstrations des ateliers et puis des
jeux de piste pour les enfants et
dernier temps fort à saint germain en
laye ont fait un peu le tour du
département vous voyez à saint germain
la chapelle royale du château il y aura
des découvertes en musique de textes sur
les jardins donc à 18h30 le dimanche 29
voilà pour les temps forts il ya bien
d'autres choses bien sûr vous le lisiez
ont fait un peu le tour du département
c'est l'occasion pour les yvelinois de
découvrir des jardins un peu hors du
commun qu'ont qu'on n'aurait pas l'idée
de faire chez soi peut-être voilà alors
surtout des jardins qui ouvre
exceptionnellement il ya des différents
jardins qu'on découvre pour la première
fois qu'ils ont des deux très jolis noms
par exemple y en a un qui s'appelle le
jardin desclaux parade miens safrané il
est très joli nom c'est ta ville est un
petit peu au sud de mantes-la-jolie sa
magnifique jardin des épices donc on
peut découvrir et qui n'ouvre pas
habituellement et et qu'on découvrira
exceptionnellement il ya aussi le jardin
de monsieur madame leur billet à orgeval
là on découvrira tout un tas de trucs
d'astuces pour faire des boutures plein
de choses un peu un peu étonnante à
dampierre le jardin de madame cambournac
enfin bon voilà plein de jardin étonnant
un peu sur tout le département que vous
ne pourrez pas visité à d'autres moments
que maintenant si on les rate c'est fini
alors pourquoi les portes sont closes
après faut peut-être attendre la
troisième édition de paroles de
jardinier en tout cas dans cette édition
il ya cent quatre-vingt dix huit
animations dont 60% sont gratuites dont
il faut vraiment profiter
on a envie de sortir c'est gratuit c'est
pas souvent c'est le cas aussi je crois
de là
visite de dimanche avec votre parent
dimanche au château c'est gratuit donc
c'est pareil c'est pas souvent qu'on
peut aller de versailles gratuitement
vous qui connaissez un peu tous ces
jardins comme vous participez évidemment
à la programmation il y en a peut-être
un qui vous attire un peu plus que les
autres n'en vous auriez préféré dans
tout dans tous ces endroits magnifiques
à il y en a qui sont très dépaysant
alors moi j'aime bien le dépaysement
effectivement à chevreuse
il ya le jardin d'émeraude qui est un
jardin de bambous
donc on a la pression qu'on est un petit
peu à certains moments aux nazis donc
voilà ça fait partie peut être deux mais
de mes coups de coeur et ils participent
à tous nos événements depuis très très
longtemps je le vois évoluer ce jardin
et voilà ça fait partie oui de mes coups
de coeur
les visiteurs en fin de compte vont
pouvoir voyager à travers le monde là
pendant pendant un mois c'est un peu ça
c'est un fait ça c'est un peu ça et
finalement ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure beaucoup sont gratuits on a un
dépaysement à deux pas de chez soi donc
voilà l'intérêt de parole de jardiniers
et puis oubliée quand même que cette
manifestation sont intéressés les
changes de trucs d'astuces d'expérience
avec le jardinier et quand soi-même en à
son petit jardin
ça peut être intéressant de découvrir
les pratiques des autres jardiniers avec
cette manifestation qui était parole de
jardiner on a vraiment l'impression que
le jardinage en france et dans les
yvelines est de plus en plus présent
c'est une passion vraiment des français
voilà ça fait partie des premières
pratiques de loisirs des français
sa figure à la deuxième ou troisième
position je crois aussi que cette année
encore deux petites questions que parole
de jarny s'inscrit dans l'année le nôtre
également exactement donc bon ça tombe
bien parce qu'effectivement les jardins
de nous deux c'est versailles et saint
germain d'où l'ouverture et la clôture
de nos événements par séparent ces deux
grands sites très connue des yvelines
combien de visiteurs vous attendez un
petit peu partout dans les yvelines dans
tous et tous ces lieux magnifiques mais
au moins la même chose que l'année
dernière on était autour de 21 mille
visiteurs l'année dernière
très bien donc rendez vous dès demain ce
samedi 7 septembre jusqu'au 29 septembre
c'est ça un peu partout dans les
yvelines si on veut découvrir le
jardinage et finalement il fait vous
voyez qu'on espère merci beaucoup
sylvie d'être venus et à très bientôt
pour pour par le jardinier notamment est
très bientôt
le week-end dernier rambouillet rendait
hommage aux agriculteurs au 60e festival
de la terre au programme découverte de
la profession évidemment mais aussi
quelques animations pour le moins
surprenant quand les courses de
tracteurs patrick jacques de dixmude est
passé au volant
le festival de la terre à rambouillet et
ses produits du terroir mais aussi ses
promenades en calèche
ces démonstrations d'engins agricoles et
surtout ces compétitions il m'a tendu
comme cette course de tracteurs
chaque tondeuse et est unique parce
qu'elle les a tous bricoler différemment
eux
la nôtre il faut éviter de débrayer de
freiner quoi il faut essayer de ne pas
qu'ils alors le problème aussi c'est la
direction parce que les virages très
serrés et on a du mal à
on a du mal à tourner
ce rendez vous organisé par les jeunes
agriculteurs de l'île de france et aussi
pour le public l'occasion de rencontres
louis est venu avec sa batteuse à poste
fixe de machines à l'abandon à qui il a
donné une seconde jeunesse
moi je suis passionné du matériel donc
j'ai vu cette machine qui était à la
pluie donc les sorties et vernier où on
la laisse tollé à ça marche très bien
elle avait fait qu'une campagne de
battage est le tournoi que l'acier de
tous est terré traiter les bestioles
qu'on croit qu'elles coupent l'intérieur
car moi ça c'est quelque chose
ancestrale parce que moi j'ai 55 ans
j'ai vu sa tournée tout gamin en bourse
les cds meirieu souvenir c'est le
parchemin vieux nostalgiques de genre
jour nostalgiques ou simplement aux
curieux le festival attire chaque année
plus de 5 mai visite
et pour le dernier week end d'août les
saint-quentinois ont voulu profiter
jusqu'au dernier moment du soleil en
famille ultime barbecue avant la rentrée
scolaire ambiance vacances à la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
patrick jacques de dixmude encore lui à
déguster pour nous quelques grillades
les braises commence à rougir la
glacière et plein tous les ingrédients
pour une après-midi réussi semblent
réunies il faut la bonne viande et
boire frais et puis toujours pareil la
libye qu'elle a pu mais aussi et puis
surtout surtout une bonne cordialité une
bonne camaraderie et des bons amis
autour du mythique barre de coupe un peu
plus loin sous les arbres
une autre famille habituée de la base de
loisirs est venu profiter du soleil
saint quentinois avant la rentrée au
menu salade de crudités poulet porc
grillé cuit à l'asiatique a fait des
barbecues arrivé à bombay surtout c'est
des enfants même si je suis venu pour
surtout pour les enfants parce que c'est
bientôt la rentrée scolaire
j'en profite et un peu parce que via un
bon moment on pense que l'un d'entre eux
jour c'est la rentrée scolaire est ce
qui fait que bon peut-être en parler
beau temps après et avec les mains c'est
encore meilleur
après s'être régalé les enfants
profitent du hamac
pendant que les adultes rinck une
dernière fois aux vacances mais
attention à consommer avec modération
les braises commencera rougis
et pour finir cette émission place au
sport depuis plusieurs semaines elle est
l'objet de toutes les curiosités la
piste au record du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est en train
d'être posées à l'heure actuelle nous
vous proposons des images exclusives de
cet anneau uniques en europe avec
patrick jacques de dixmude ils la font
naître là tu après lattes depuis deux
semaines une douzaine d'ouvriers
s'attelle à la tâche à coups de marteau
pour donner vie à la piste record du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
250 mètres de long pour 8 mètres de
large
l'anneau sera unique au monde avec une
pente plus importante qu'ailleurs une
inclinaison de 44 degrés la piste
permettra aux cyclistes de monter plus
haut et de prendre plus d'élan pour
faire tomber les records du monde et
c'est aussi dans sa composition même que
ce pain venu tout droit de sibérie
délivre ses secrets il a la
particularité d'être une essence très
dur de croître très lentement et donc
d'être très peu soumis aux variations
d'hydrométrie c'est un des matériaux qui
permet aussi d'avoir le plus de
rendement
donc de restituer l'énergie des coureurs
et ce qui est très important pour
pouvoir gagner de la vitesse et des
kilomètres heure cet écrin de bois
réalisée par l'architecte ralph schumann
coûte environ un million d'euros
l'enceinte accueillera près de 5000
personnes et d'éventuelles compétitions
de basket de volley ball pourrait s'y
dérouler nous allons rester sur le vélo
mais cette fois ci pour un tour d'europe
il s'appelle t au bourg dont il a 25 ans
il est revenu à guyancourt mi août à peu
près après avoir traversé pas moins de
20 pays et parcouru plus de 16 mille
kilomètres il est venu dans le 7-8 sport
cette semaine nous raconter cette
expérience inédite
je vais certainement changer la majorité
des pièces de mon vélo puisque au bout
de seize mille kilomètres vous pouvez
imaginer l'état d'usure des pièces la
majorité des vélos que vous voyez dans
la rue faut peut-être mille kilomètres
dans l'année
seize mille kilomètres c'est énorme donc
je vais changer tout un tas de pièces
mais je vous avec sérieux vrai comme
panne
ageca s'est énormément de pièces j'ai
caché dont deux roues arrière une roue
avant un porte bagages
le boîtier de pédalier en fait tout ce
qui est roulement ou les pièces qui sont
soumis à rude contrainte c'est à dire
les roues voilà donc j'ai fait changer
tout ça de nombreuses fois en allant
vous avez découvert beaucoup de paysages
qu'elle est quel a été le moment le plus
sympa peut-être le plus émouvant sur la
route le moment le plus émouvant je
dirais que c'était la partie grèce les
deux mois que j'ai passé en grèce ont
été absolument formidable et plus
particulièrement les deux semaines que
j'ai passées en crète
ça a été absolument fabuleux au niveau
des paysages ou des rencontres et
surtout des paysages pour la pour la
grèce voilà les rencontres je réserverai
plutôt ça à l'europe de l'est j'ai été
assez surpris des rencontres que j'ai
fait de la qualité de ces rencontres
c'était l'accueil dans l'europe de l'est
si on prend l'accueil était exceptionnel
les gens
ont très peu de choses
mais sont prêts à tout vous offrir vous
faire manger avec eux on est considéré
presque comme de la famille et des fois
ça a été même très difficile de faire
les au revoir
des larmes qui coulent alors que
finalement on est on connaissait
personne depuis que simplement quelques
jours donc c'est très beau très fort en
émotions vous le disiez tout à l'heure
vous avez été accompagné pendant presque
six mois à peu près par un ami d'enfance
qui vous a quitté après vous étiez seul
sur la route il ya dû avoir un moment
difficile
une grosse remise en question non tout à
fait j'étais pas vraiment préparé au
voyage en solitaire forcément beaucoup
de risques sur la route
canton pour les campements c'est à dire
que j'ai dormi dans la nature la plupart
du temps donc j'avais peur également des
animaux sauvage les sangliers les chiens
j'en ai croisé tout un tas et donc pour
toutes ces raisons là j'étais pas
vraiment préparé à voyager en solitaire
maintenant je suis resté positif toulon
j'ai su rester fort mentalement et
continuer à aller de l'avant toujours
voilà c'est une véritable épreuve avec
vous même peut-être tendance pendant
toute cette année à vous et vous avez
peut-être appris à mieux vous connaître
aussi non c'est vrai on apprend ses
limites car là on repousse ses limites
c'est ça on titille les limites je les
sens j'ai beaucoup écouté tous très
proches des limites voilà tutoyer les
limites de nombreuses fois lors de ce
voyage
et c'est vrai que c'est très dur dans
ces moments-là de garder un bon mental
et de continuer à avancer donc le la
plus dure la période la plus difficile
pour moi ça a été après le passage de
mes parents et de ma copine en grèce
voilà c'était une semaine absolument
formidable mais quand ils sont partis je
me suis retrouvée seule à nouveau et
pendant une bonne semaine ça a été très
difficile de l'avancé pour les féminines
de l'entente le chesnay versailles c'est
la saison de tous les défis après leur
montée historique en nationale une de
basket en juin dernier les yvelinoises
vont se battre pour le maintien dans une
poule assez ouverte cette saison
nouvelles joueuses nouvel encadrement
nous avons fait le point il ya quelques
jours avec jonathan vim
ce guêpier droit il est le nouvel homme
fort de l'entente le chesnay-versailles
stéphane drolet a débarqué cet été du
droit de franconville dans le val d'oise
et du pôle espoir féminin régional
épaulé par cyril marcos il n'est pas
venu les mains vides sur le mans
yvelinois quelques anciennes joueuses de
franconville font partie du voyage
diana gandega l'internationale malienne
qui a participé aux jeux olympiques de
2008 et melanie b est passé par les
équipes de france jeunes un recrutement
malin qui semble prendre le tempo du
groupe pour l'instant très bon état de
santé bon un nouvel entraîneur c'est
toujours particulier
surtout quand on replace un entraîneur
qui a
avec une montée le groupe est peut-être
un petit guide mais la nôtre se passe
bien théorie après c'est aux jo je vais
vous dire ça se passe super bien ici
sont conscientes avons rien à me
connaissez déjà un petit peu d'avant par
le biais des compétitions il viana j'ai
joué avec l année dernière donc ça
facilite aussi l'intégration on n'arrive
pas tout seul quand on est sur une série
de victoires comme ils ont fait avec une
monte forcément on a toujours dans
l'enthousiasmé dans la joie qui
s'étripent après tout qu elle perdure
donc au chapitre style de jeu l'ancien
entraîneur vinko berdych qui a arrêté sa
carrière et stéphane drolet aurait pu
bien s'entendre
les yvelinoises joueront comme la saison
dernière avec une défense très agressive
et une circulation de balle où les
joueuses devraient pouvoir s'exprimer
mais pour l'instant place au travail de
passes blessés surtout reprendre
tranquillement donc on avait beaucoup de
physique la semaine dernière au toujours
le ballon cette semaine on n'est plus
dans la préparation du collectif et
défense et et offensif et on commencera
les matches amicaux en fin de semaine
prochaine pour voir où on en est bon
voilà
l'idée c'est qu'on soit prêt pour les
deux de deuxième troisième match de
championnat on sera comme toutes les
équipes en rodage
le fcv pourra s'appuyer encore quelques
mois sur cécile dansèrent la pivot
historique du club qui n'a pas encore
repris l'entraînement fera une dernière
pige jusqu'en décembre avant de quitter
les parquets pour assurer le maintien en
nationale une
premier test ce jeudi en amical face au
club tchèque de kara troupe 9 et pour ce
premier match amical justement les
joueuses de stéphane drolet se sont bien
battus et en face au quatrième de la
ligue tchèque mais elles se sont
inclinées qui 77 à 65 pour la cinquième
année consécutive plus de 400 enfants
ont pu apprendre les réflexes vitaux
dans le haut ils ont passé l'épreuve du
sauv'nage à la piscine de la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines un
minimum parfois difficiles à effectuer
reportage réalisé avec elodie moines
bref comme ça 1 2 3 4
mes bras en étoile ou allongé sur le dos
serena tente de garder la tête hors de
l'eau
elle passe les cinq étapes du sauv'nage
ce diplôme créé par l'école de natation
française pour faire prendre conscience
à ces jeunes de leur capacité à assurer
leur sécurité dans l'eau c'est le
minimum vital l'eminem vitale surtout
pour pouvoir retrouver le bord
être amené à sauver lors d'une chute et
voilà les mots mêmes qui permet
justement de sortir sans être aidé un
minimum vital qui varient en fonction de
l'origine sociale des enfants âgés de 11
à 17 ans ils sont issus de zones
urbaines sensibles et pour ce groupe de
saint-cyr-l'ecole faire la bouteille où
flottait sur le ventre on était des
formalités facile mais c'était bien pour
l'ol est un peu froid mais c'est une
façon chercher à nos et puis tu
reprennes été dur en fait il serait
possible
pourtant sur les quatre jours de
l'opération peu sont repartis avec leur
diplôme en poche cette opération comme
celle-ci sont vraiment pourquoi tu es du
doigt le fait que nos jeunes ne savent
pas nager nous on a eu ici que quelques
pourcentages qui réussissent le test
environ 5 à 10% sur l'ensemble des
jeunes puisque on en accueille 100 par
jour sur les quatre journées contre 50,1
plus de 400 adolescents franciliens ont
passé le test du sauv'nage l'année
dernière un enfant de 5 ans avait perdu
la vie dans le bassin de la base de
loisirs cet été deux personnes se sont
noyées dans les yvelines
et pour finir cette émission place à vos
rendez-vous du week-end si vous n'avez
pas encore inscrire votre enfant dans un
club pour la nouvelle saison il est
encore temps et vous pourrez les profité
du forum des associations ce week-end ce
samedi un précisément un peu partout à
saint quentin en yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux
rendez vous au centre sportif pierre de
coubertin de 9h à 19h à la verrière au
scarabée
rendez vous à 14 heures seulement
l'après midi 14h 18h et puis encore au
complexe sportif de la clé saint-pierre
à elancourt de 9h à 17h et puis pour
plus de renseignements je vous renvoie
au site internet des communes en sport
en football le championnat de promotion
d'honneur reprend ses droits ce week-end
dans la poule c le fbi en cours
accueillent ce dimanche montfermeil au
stade maurice baquet coup d'envoi à
15h30 et dans la poule b l'étoile
sportive de trappes se déplace à mantes
la jolie
ce 7,8 week-end touche à sa fin la
semaine prochaine dans kiosque votre
émission culture aurélia de lui si vous
présentera une édition spéciale sur les
journées européennes du patrimoine
et pour ma part je vous retrouverai dans
le 7-8 sport avec arnaud faux
l'entraîneur des couguars de montigné
après leur demi finale de division 2
en baseball à pessac en aquitaine d'ici
là excellent week-end